in late october over a hundred container
ships floated in the waters outside of
la waiting to unload at the dock the
global pandemic triggered sky-high
consumer spending on manufactured goods
as opposed to vacations or other
services so this bottleneck will persist
according to supply chain analysts like
laura cesari we're going to be facing
shortages on the retail shelf electric
tools home goods computers and monitors
for special clothing those goods are on
their ships in the middle of the ocean
we'll have shortages for the holidays
and then we'll have a lot of inventory
because we will have unloaded those
containers too late let's follow a
single container uh how about that one
over there yeah on its epic journey
along the supply chain to find out where
exactly things are breaking down
since its invention in 1956 the modern
container was a game changer for the
shipping industry you can't talk about
supply chain without talking about
containers according to some estimates
95 percent of manufactured goods now
move across the world on shipping
containers a container allows the
shipper to transport a box from a rail
car or a trucker onto a ship and then to
take the box off the ship onto a rail
car or a truck and move it without
opening the container and without
disturbing the goods which helps us
eliminate theft and damage welcome to
the port of shanghai china the busiest
port in the world where our container
no no the one on the right yes that's
the one good old c183277251
is one of over 30 million 20-foot
containers move through this port
annually our container is loaded onto a
truck and travels to a manufacturing
center in wangju china to be loaded up
by a forklift with 3 500 pairs of shoes
part of a big order for walmart in the
united states the containers are loaded
at a manufacturing site and then they're
sealed which basically says that it has
been prepared for shipping with its
passage to long beach california booked
our container is sent back to the port
of shanghai where it is moved to the
dock and onto its designated ship
there's our container being moved onto
the ship by a robot crane they're very
sophisticated they're the most
sophisticated in europe more
sophisticated in asia than in north
america the north american shipping
industry has been resistant to move to
high automation of the cranes our
container is now ready to cross the
pacific ocean the next phase of its long
journey to a walmart in chicago a large
retailer might have a purchase order
that will cover multiple containers i've
seen a single purchase order for walmart
cover 50 different containers our
container will spend 20 to 30 days at
sea stacked alongside 15 000 other
shipping containers
to carry a super sized load you need a
supersized ship to cut costs shipping
vessels have become a lot bigger over
the past few years and that means they
take a lot more time to unload many
smaller ports can handle these big boys
putting pressure on large ports like la
that are already struggling to handle
the spike in demand caused by pandemic
consumer spending patterns which are
centered on imported goods when you have
this much volume you have a black hole
in the supply chain and you don't know
necessarily what's on each container and
the issue is that containers don't have
authoritative identifiers so while
you'll go to the grocery store and
you'll buy a pack of diamond scanner it
has a unique identifier a container will
have a number but you've got to see the
number and it's hard to see the number
on the ship also the numbers may not be
intact after a month at sea our shipping
container comes within view of the port
of long beach together with la these
sister ports handle 40 percent of
america's inbound sea freight and
traffic is way up because consumers
still rattled by the pandemic keep
spending their money on manufactured
goods the satellite image for the ports
and southern california show upwards of
a hundred container ships at sea most of
them are waiting 10 15 20 days and
they're just sitting out waiting their
cube waiting to be called if the ocean
container carrying ships are not given a
spot on the dock they just sit and wait
and one of the issues is sometimes they
can experience weather and when weather
happens some of the containers fall off
the ships and they fall into the ocean
one to five percent of containers will
actually fall into the ocean the
containers that fall off the ships will
basically bob in the ocean sometimes you
know the goods will get wet and
sometimes they won't more than 3 000
containers went overboard in 2021 but
our container survived the two-week
weight and its ship finally pulls up to
the dock then the longshoremen using
cranes start to unload the containers
one at a time our container goes onto a
chassis that's being pulled by a trucker
with a cab to be moved to an inland hub
a process which is known as draij the
drainage piece of the supply chain is
long it can be a day a day and a half
two days so why does it take that long
to move our container essentially a half
mile the united states ports are some of
the most inefficient ports in the world
if we want to look at port efficiency we
should go to europe and look at the work
that maersk is doing in rotterdam or the
port of antwerp those ports have been
invested in and they're streamlined and
much higher visibility less variability
than what we have in the united states
ports in america aren't centrally
managed or maintained by governments the
way highways are they're often owned by
a mishmash of private terminal operators
there is no centralized control tower or
signal to be able to synchronize all of
these pieces to be able to align for the
supply chain lack of centralized
coordination at the port is really
obvious when it comes to trucking there
are over 100 000 chassis in long beach
and la alone many of those chassis are
not functional
and they're not enough and the lack of
really good facilities for the truckers
to get to the chassis and get to the
docks we don't have good synchronization
of the truck drivers to the docks the
drayage trucker carrying our container
has a very small cab designed for quick
turns in the tight spaces at ports to
get to a distribution center we will
need a bigger truck to pick up our
container from the inland yard and take
the long haul across the country
if we are transporting goods from long
beach to walmart it'll be five to seven
days on the road for the truck driver
when the container gets to a
distribution center receivers look at
the number of the container match it to
the paperwork they have it will then be
unloaded put onto belts and sorted the
turnaround in a walmart distribution
center if those goods are needed at
retail is 10 to 24 hours it's quick
sometimes the supply chain doesn't work
very well either the walmart
distribution center might be full
or the demand at the store changes
significantly so
the container could be moved directly to
the store from either the distribution
center to basically wait for unloading
when the store is ready for it you may
see containers on chassis or containers
on parking lots waiting to be unloaded
at the store itself but in the case of
our container it is then moved by rail
empty to an inland yard by train stacked
onto a chassis at the port and hopefully
placed onto a ship back to asia soon but
that could take weeks or months but
because of the pressures on the ports
many of those empty containers are
sitting on chassis in those inland rail
yards and that's twofold of an issue one
because it's tying up chassis and the
second is we need to get those empty
containers back to asia to complete the
route many truckers are having trouble
returning empties so you see a lot of
truck drivers are just dropping empty
containers and chassis which is becoming
a nuisance for a lot of the areas around
the ports so how do we fix this mess and
keep the containers moving we need to
think about how do we resolve the
chassis issue we need to invest how we
move goods chassis free we basically
unload through the cranes onto something
like hyperloop to be able to move those
containers inland in these
areas in california where land is so
premium and it's just not available near
the port because it's landlocked into
the inland hubs so that the drivers
don't have to deal with the southern
california traffic problems so
investigating how we could move
containers without chassis should be a
high priority an investment there so
after a three-month journey across the
globe our box comes back home to china
to begin the supply chain cycle again
[Music]